you know what i find funny too is like i
think there's going to be a ton of
content for the biden presidency oh yeah
in terms of like gaffes and like yes but
they can't make fun of him
it's like you can't spend four years
being like orange men is bad and i get
joe biden it's like
well i mean biden i got hairy legs
i know we had we had a field day with
them there were
cockroaches in the pool that's
gonna be hilarious i think you're you're
in for a gold mine i am now that's the
thing if biden wins like it'll
probably be really good for my channel a
lot of money because biden gaff
videos the the videos where like i
animate
one of joe biden's audio clips usually
do really well
and it's a lot of fun for me also but i
would rather
the country not be destroyed well i
guess i guess the bigger issue is
they're like like i said the vampire is
still going to need to feed
yep and they're going to come after
people they're going to come after me
they're
special they're gonna have sheamus
arrangement syndrome they're gonna keep
talking like look at what james is
tweeting today
no shouldn't he be more responsible as a
cartoonist
i think uh people take him seriously if
the gop holds the senate
and uh biden takes the presidency it's
not the worst thing in the world
the worst thing would be like democrats
taking everything because then we would
start to see these truth and reckon
silly commit
reconciliation commissions let me let me
let me show you what we got we got we
got some of this first we've got some of
this hopefully
october 11th healing us divides through
truth and reconciliation
i cannot wait yeah healing the division
it has been divided and we must it we
must be
healed they say america is cliche blah
blah blah i get it
missions heal us check this out the
whole point lydia of commissions i don't
see it the washington post is saying
we're not allowed to read the news
nonsense
wouldn't it be funny if the washington
post like based on your voting record
would hide articles from you like no you
know you don't deserve to be informed
you know they do that wait what not
based on your voting record based on
your region
so news outlets based on your region
will serve up different front pages to
you and different headlines
wow yeah they've been doing it for a
long time when i actually i've i think
i've seen that there was um
someone took a picture of a newspaper
from two different regions but it was
literally
like right next to each other the
newspaper stands were right next to each
other but it was a democrat
it was a yeah yeah so like what will
happen is news outlets
can detect where you're from when you
log in
for the most part let's use a vpn or
something and then it'll say it'll show
a picture of donald trump
and he's like you know throwing
something
and then like one headline will say like
donald trump gives out gifts to fans
but then in the democrat area area will
say donald trump throw throws trash on
the floor
you know like so i'm i'm making that but
you look you get the point so tim do you
think on the other side of the country
it says that donald trump has 264
electoral votes and joe biden has 214.
i win it's not like that they're just
going to alive they're just going to lie
to us for the next four years
it depends on right yeah it depends on
the framing like it depends on
100 they want to maximize traffic so
they'll frame it
but a lot of these outlets that are
pumping out orange man bad content
which really did hurt trump like they
just
they just want the money yeah what are
they going to do i am so excited for
this you know why
like dude i'm one guy you know my over
my overhead on my main channels is
it's just me yeah literally i don't even
have to buy stuff i did buy cameras and
a computer and all that stuff
and then i went i pay myself and i do
work for all these news outlets
this is what i try to explain uh to
people when they talk about why media
was dying before donald trump and it was
it was bad
i worked for you know the abc uh news
univision joint venture
and they were trying to figure out how
to make content make money the only
problem is
they're competing with people posting
pictures of cats and dogs on facebook
so you get this this news outlet says we
want to capture attention
that's what we're selling and then
advertisers can be on that attention
yeah exactly
you got to pay someone 40 to 50 000 a
year to work in this office
as a multimedia expert that means
whenever they make a piece of content
which they can make
you know depending on if they're writing
or making if they're doing a video it's
going to be once a week if that
then you get every single american with
a smartphone
filming their little dog and like like
it's like a video of a cat like getting
ready to jump and the cat slips and
falls and they'll laugh and
there's videos of goats yelling like
people and it was all
free free 100 free for
facebook and for youtube and for twitter
and and instagram
so what happens is youtube wants
attention facebook wants attention they
sell the same thing as the news outlets
attention advertising space but they're
getting everything
for free and giving nothing yep so the
media companies were desperate
they were like how do we get video
content that'll capture attention if we
have to pay for it and facebook doesn't
they were losing well then along came
the orange men
and they were like oh they're like i
think he's bad now
you can get people putting the phone up
i think trump is bad
but it's not nearly as entertaining as
political commentary and news content
and
shock content and police brutality
videos so then news outlets started
focusing heavily on whatever they could
to get that attention
if trump goes i think we're going to see
the end of
all of these blogs you know that's a
silver line before before trump this was
back in i think 2014.
uh 2015. shane smith the uh former i
believe he's the former ceo of ice said
there was going to be a bloodbath in
digital media they all knew that the
media was dying
they could not do anything about it now
we're looking at tucker carlson he's got
the highest highest ratings in history
and yet 5.3 million
and average he can't find advertisers
isn't that interesting no he's got the
my pillow guy then my pillow guy is
basically yeah
but it's incredible my pillow guy came
in clutch i love that but
well that's the truth and reconciliation
that's coming yeah so so what i what i
see happening next is
we're sort of trapped in a cultural
addiction spiral
where if biden ends up winning and it's
extremely close
and either either way the the voters who
came out for biden
are the product of the media addiction
to
desperately trying to get traffic and
attacking trump all day non-stop
there's an article that came out that
said something like 98 percent of all
joke
political jokes stand-up jokes were
about trump only 2 were about biden
so they're they're they're desperately
trying to do whatever they can to get
traffic
and thus they've created an army of
people who will vote trump out
destroying themselves in the process
because he was the only thing they could
use to get
interest yeah i think i think obama at a
rally recently was like could you
imagine
waking up not talking about donald trump
and everyone cheers and laughs and it's
like
i could they can't imagine it like in
january on this show we're talking about
sonic the hedgehog
yeah like we had to wait a whole segment
like man son that movie was great
we were chilling we're having a good
time and then covet happened and then
everyone went insane now an election
cycle and then we became very very
political and i'm like dude
if if trump goes my overhead is like
nothing
meaning i just i'm a guy who looks at a
camera and talks about his feelings on
the internet
if you're very open and vulnerable with
us which i appreciate
what do you mean about your feelings he
is yes no i was just kidding
yeah yeah that's tim he's all about
feelings if if trump loses i go back to
making videos about what i what what i'm
thinking and feeling
and some like i remember a year and a
half ago i did a video about
there was a uh two women outside of a
bar and a dude came up and they swung at
him and he punched he punched her and he
got arrested
like that video was no like particularly
powerful news relevance
i saw a story and i was like wow that's
crazy and so i did a segment talking
about i was like this is really crazy
like watching this video like the guy
got arrested why did the guy get
arrested he didn't do anything wrong
and so that's what i was doing but what
happens to these media outlets what are
they going to talk about
they like they've propped themselves up
the bigger issue is i know they can
write about dogs tripping over you know
toilet roll paper balls or whatever yeah
but they have overhead
they've got to pay the salary and the
problem is the amount of money they have
to pay
these people versus the return they get
from the content they produce
is lower than their then you know it's
less money than the salary meaning it's
not it's not sustainable
yeah good i think i don't like them i
think if trump loses
then what's going to happen to the media
is they're going to collapse
which is going to give rise to
independent commentary low overhead
internet video
and then we are going to see probably
something
really weird happen in 2024 yeah i'm
curious about that
drew what do you think i think that
voter fraud is absolutely real
um i think even in the 2020 primaries
like in wisconsin
pennsylvania virginia we had all kinds a
whole host of issues
like tens of thousands of ballots that
were returned that were rejected because
of bad signatures false information like
there was all kinds of issues that were
going on in the primaries and i think
what's going on right now is
i can't sit here and say that like i
can't see that happening right now
because we just went through four years
of one impeachment attempt
that failed with zero evidence zero
evidence on record
and then a second attempt with zero
evidence that was successful
right they impeached donald trump over
nothing
literally over nothing so so so for
people to sit here and say that
it's a conspiracy theory to think that
the left could be really doing things to
rig this election
is not too far-fetched in my opinion
they told us by any means necessary
absolutely yeah and they also contested
the results of a free and democratic
election for
four straight years so they're clearly
not that invested in the process
well so so uh why don't the republic
well the republicans will never do this
and that's why they should all be voted
out but
they could launch a special
investigation into biden's ukraine
dealings
yeah they totally could yep well get 47
million dollars investigate
all his connections and this is one of
the things i said one of the things i
said was that if biden is elected if the
republicans do not go after him with
everything that they have
every single one of them deserves to be
voted out because biden has done
truly egregious things in ukraine he's
enabled his son to do awful things he's
given him
he's gotten money for his son and he's
just used the power of the presidency to
do whatever
the fact that he flew his son joe biden
flew his son to china
on air force two government taxpayer
dollars
so that his son could negotiate a
massive private equity deal that would
make him rich
is joe biden using the power of the
office to enrich his family 100
which goes to his family like that's
that's it it's like well joe biden
himself didn't take the money i don't
care
joe biden's already rich oh so when he's
when he's retiring his son buys him a
mansion
but that's his son buying the money yeah
he used government resources
and and and access to get his son these
meetings the biden's
i thought he was working class joe yeah
exactly right no malarkey joe sounds
like malarkey to me
no no no no look scranton joe just
happened to have a kid who grew up to do
international private equity deals with
chinese communists yeah you know it's
it's a normal thing middle america it's
not sound american
yeah i i just did a a a billion dollar
private equity deal with china
you know like my neighbor yeah my
neighbor is uh he's a goat farmer
yeah he did one too yeah exactly that's
not
he who is without a one billion dollar
china deal may cast the first
yeah stone course dude it's gonna be
it's gonna be hilarious if joe biden
wins
uh i don't know what's gonna happen man
but i know that it's gonna be like
you know people like to say clown world
yeah yeah that's that's gonna be it like
could you imagine actually i think it's
fair to point out i may be a little bit
optimistic here because
like how long joe biden how long is your
body gonna last i have no idea i like to
i mean i imagine he'll step down
after about a year and then calm will be
the president because i don't think
he'll step down
you know they will something i think
he's gonna be forcibly removed ooh
nancy pelosi put together do you think
he want you think he'll be forcibly
removed like do you think joe biden
wants to be president
here's my prediction um i i am actually
kind of leaning towards trump getting a
court victory
but i i i don't know i don't know it's a
toss-up it really is like
that press conference trump did earlier
who's sad
i thought it was sad 100 like he was sad
yeah yeah he was like quite frankly we
did really well but uh there was fraud
and
it was like there was no energy there
was there was no uh strength behind it
and it it did not seem
confidence-building but
uh so that's why i'm like it's toss-up
but i do
think i wouldn't know which way it's
going to go
i i would i think people would be nuts
to underestimate trump's base of support
um and the accusations and the and the
videos that are popping up need to be
investigated
trump might go to the courts and they
might say in nevada
we found 20 thousand ballots for
whatever reason are disqualified and
then trump wins and then trump wins in a
vessel and that's something people
understand this people like that's not
that's not abnormal right like the
public
and our our our population has been
convinced because of kovid that like
mail-in ballot voting
is like successful yes that's not that's
not it's
times warned us about it in 2012 right
they said that that's literally the most
uh probable abused version of voting
form of voting but that's that totally
i'm not super concerned about that right
now i mean
like i think the issue right now is
the the past deadline ballots and
there's uh there was a a republican
uh poll watcher who said he saw an
unidentifiable woman shuffle a stack of
ballots in with another sack of ballots
so that
they're not you know segregating the
ballots between those that come in after
election day
it's possible that trump goes to the
supreme court and they say how many
ballots in in
you know georgia or in nevada were
from after election day and we have hard
data saying it was 20 000.
cut them out i mean in the trump
campaign sent observers
to observe the ballot counting and then
they're starting to put
i mean even important letters they're
boarding up windows like if you have
nothing to hide then why are you guys
boarding up why were the democrats
they're worried about those republican
rioters who are going to lose their
minds
why did democrats appeal right
right why are they appealing trump block
trump's people
from observing whatever no that's what i
want to talk about i want i want to
understand why if you have nothing to
hide
then why are you trying to hide
something you're sounding like the nsa
and i don't care listen i don't care
republican democrat trump supporter
biden supporter i was texting
i was telling lydia this the other night
it's like i i
i'm ready and i am i think mature enough
to take a massive l yeah as a trump
supporter yeah you're not going to see
me screaming at the sky
because joe biden right here
i'm not i'm not going to be screaming at
this that's actually what i want
what do i want integrity truth and
honesty they've made
they've made a meme where they
superimpose trump's face on that woman
it's funny i thought it was hilarious
but it's also kind of sad for them
because that's the only way they could
have gotten it
yeah the only way they could get a
conservative dropping to their knees and
screaming note this guy
was to superimpose trump's face on their
own you know
ally yeah thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you